[Music]
these farm workers are the backbone of
California's Coachella Valley the fuel
and agriculture industry that brings in
six hundred and fifty million dollars in
revenue annually many of them are also
undocumented and now living under fear
of deportation
[Music]
we travel to the Coachella Valley to
hear their stories
[Music]
we are complicit positions Ptolemy V
demo compo
in Sao Tome hola gente c'è vida no mas
Mira todo todo Latinos comenzamos en el
campo trabajando Quan Elpidio con el
calor Altos de alimentos un trabajo
Campo es importante porque why Obama
tilde a la visas todos los chicos de los
Millonarios ephors Sen Mexicano no lo
haces que por Abajo una merit on okra
telomere estando aqui es and are echad
o's sandal in kados de lo que se hace no
todos NACO Cittadella track osa trabajo
es pasado no cargando
[Music]
Florentino Alvarez is an agricultural
contractor who places workers and jobs
in Coachella citrus fields
yah-hey de llegar y siempre and oyakodon
onl feel por el nido la mera también
puede que ahora cuando cuando lo hacen
siempre or Ito DNA nose
Florentino is now a legal resident and
owns his own business he worries many of
his workers won't be around to harvest
crops during the all-important high
season que todo rancheros Camino tiempo
todos que debe scar
so prodotto innocent who knows hey Anza
carro y lo ji e no kaidan salir a
trabajar
these fields are a test of mental and
physical endurance in the summer months
temperatures can reach up to 120 degrees
even in the heat workers have to cover
themselves up entirely to protect
against the Sun and
all of that for an annual income just
above the federal poverty level Labor
Department figures show farmworkers in
Coachella Valley make about $21,000 a
year in quarantine Kwan's trabajando en
estos travail nunca is tuned americano a
purse trabajo de lo mexican see y el
presidente piensa que el hierro vamos a
trabajo los Americanos puede venir a he
lays so fresco trabajo within his first
two weeks in office President Trump
signed several executive orders aimed at
stronger immigration enforcement that
includes hiring 15,000 additional ice
and Border Patrol agents and it also
makes more people a priority for
deportation even those who haven't been
charged with a crime
yeah no puede salir mucho para miedo de
que NOS para el policía ya de que el
policía el trabajo que el quiere que
este de NOS papal SEO no no tiene que
para nós algunas los hijos tienen mucho
miedo era era trabajar manejar con sus
carros en su licencia yo soon inshallah
squalor teman Kasey Vienna ya know
regresa charms aggressive stance on
illegal immigration can have a huge
impact on food production California is
the top agricultural state in the
country raking in 47 billion dollars in
2015 over a third of the country's
vegetables and two thirds of its fruits
and nuts come from California and
documented immigrants mostly from Mexico
make up about 60% of those hired to
harvest those crops the immigrants we
spoke with reminded us why they're here
in the first place no lo que es este
progra sorry you know regresamos los
well dosa a so muy uno
no pueden estar economica meant Avena
yeah driving around the city it's clear
that Coachella has a long history of
fighting for the rights of farmworkers
labor leader Cesar Chavez made a real
impact here in establishing better
working conditions however union leader
helada Torres says farm workers are
still a vulnerable population tenemos a
Price's donde la palapa Brezza grande
los ribière no Suncor optos las
compañías abusin de ESO de que tenemos
la necesidad el dinero y la mesa de esta
for now the Coachella Valley fields are
still filled with immigrant farm workers
but that could change at any moment it's
why people like Bowden thenö are taking
a page out of Chavez his book to protect
those who are here to do one thing work
Kanan el vaya Coachella's data Unni a
new group grande para tratar de ayudar a
todos gente que que no tiene el momento
y que son trabajadores de la gente que
esta
hi I'm Melissa a producer I aj+
since Trump took office and documented
people have been living with the
heightened level of fear but in our next
video you'll meet a family who refuses
to live in the shadows